now let's get into that uh that news we
got the story from real clear politics
chicago mayor lori lightfoot fop
president is attempting to induce an
insurrection by opposing vaccine mandate
i just love that line she said we
believe that the fraternal order of
police leadership is trying to foment an
illegal work stoppage or strike she said
we are not having that the contract is
clear the police unions are not
authorized to strike what we've seen
from the fraternal order of police
leadership is a lot of misinformation
and frankly flat out lies in order to
induce an insurrection and we're not
having that the law is on our side we
feel very confident about it urging
members of the department to ignore the
chain of command
let me be clear john kenzar has
destroyed his police career destroyed it
he is not fit and he is never going to
go back in any kind of active position i
don't want him to lend to to lead these
young officers astray and have them
destroy their careers like he has
destroyed his i just love the idea of an
executive
issuing an order by decree and then when
someone says i object that's an
insurrection
well that's what we get did you guys see
in seattle the cops have started flying
the gadsden flags yeah i saw that it's
become a thing now and the southwest
airlines
as well posting a lot of photos of the
gatson flags inside of the airplanes
there but but this is nothing new from
lori lightfoot i mean i am seeing a lot
of comments
talk about
beetlejuice in the comment section just
for clarification
i think it's important to bring up some
of these facts but this is the same
mayor that we have to understand uh just
a couple of months ago during the middle
of the whole covet crisis when she was
telling everyone to stay home we need to
lock down we need to punish people she
was walking the streets being like go
home right now
she also went out there and defied her
own decrees and went and got a haircut
and then told everyone well i need a
haircut i'm out in the public eye and
it's important for me to flaunt these
rules that i made up that you have to
obey
bloody weekend in chicago
uh you know what i think just just real
quick i think the funny thing is
they wanted to defund the cops
so all these guys are saying hey we're
not going to come to work this is this
should be the easiest solution she
should be in favor of this great we
wanted it to fund you anyway but it's
funny once they say we're not coming to
work now it's you guys are an
insurrection i mean
you can't have it both ways either you
defund them and you don't want them to
show up and you don't like them but
suddenly now it's i care about them and
i can't believe they're not showing up
this is why i refer to the
establishments it's mostly the democrats
in the media as the cult because it
doesn't matter what their position was
it just matters what the whim is today
before it was like the police are bad
okay everybody i agree with whatever
you've said for whatever reason defund
the police now all of a sudden the cops
are like we're gonna walk and they're
like no no you can't leave that's an
insurrection there's no real principle
behind what they do no it's just fall in
line behind the establishment behind
those in charge but but to elaborate on
the lord life thing that luke mentioned
lori lightfoot literally just posted
this yesterday at 5 24 p.m it's an image
of her violating chicago's max mask
mandates
so
you know you you ask who's doing the
insurrection the people who are breaking
the laws of this country violating the
constitution trying to rule by decree
not even following their own rules i
don't think the president himself and
and doc and joe biden were out to dinner
this weekend in georgetown a very
expensive restaurant and they get filled
with that the they wonder why people
don't take them seriously take them
seriously but it's over and over again
and what is gen soccer i mean these guys
just go
every time they get caught it's come on
seriously don't you know that's not a
big deal gavin newsom at french laundry
all these politicians one after another
on the democratic side get caught not
obeying the mandates and the
restrictions that they send for
everybody else dc's mayor eleanor
hornebs norton same thing goes to a
wedding but it's everybody else should
follow this and then they wonder why
people
don't believe and trust in them anymore
it's because of this yeah and i i just
kind of want to add to this point
because when we look at chicago i think
it's fair to argue that it's already a
mess more young people die in chicago
from gang shootings than covet
and and we have to understand the
chicago police chief
union the president of the police
union in chicago is standing up and
saying that almost 3 000 officers are
going to defy
a lot of these mandates one third of the
entire chicago police department if that
happens i i think it's fair to say
there's going to be going to be far
greater implications in chicago than we
could even uh expect to understand
if you think about it you've got cops
health care workers teachers airline
pilots the list goes on and on of all
these professions that are saying if you
force me to do something against my will
military members at what point is that
tipping point where society then really
deals with the consequences of this
right you think about all these
professions that we need who are pushing
back i don't think it's about the
vaccines i think it's about purging uh
institutions of authority so the cops
that are putting up the gadsden flags
defying the orders and quitting are the
ones who clearly have an issue with
mandated medical procedures yeah but the
people the cops who remain are going to
be like whatever
this i i agree with you i don't think
this has to do
with getting a vaccine or not at this at
the core of it this has to do with
government telling you to do something
and i and i think this has been bungled
from the beginning every day that dr
fauci's out there is a day
that creates further tension and further
confusion the end of the day if you
like dr fauci you've got vaccinated like
five months ago there's nobody out there
right now that's saying oh wait a second
dr fauci's on the air let me listen to
what he has to say to rachel maddow you
know what it's a good point you sit
there rachel if you haven't been
vaccinated do it now get four jabs and
two masks that's that's no one is
waiting
for fouchy at this point
you bought in a long time ago all
they're doing now and this weekend fauci
goes on the sunday shows and when he
gets asked about criticism of himself he
says if you criticize me
you're like a conspiracy theorist the
same guy by the way just so we're clear
one of the quotes that he gave out this
weekend is that it's probably likely
that jay and jay should have been
a second dose right think about this two
words that don't normally go with
science probably and should it's either
yes or no it's either the data shows or
not but found she's out there going
probably should have been too that
doesn't invoke confidence in the system
when the head guy is saying yeah maybe i
don't know yeah now fauci fauci didn't
just call people conspiracy theorists
that didn't like him they said that
these people are denying reality and he
said quote sometimes the truth becomes
inconvenient for some people so they
react against me
that's just is what it is i mean that's
a delusional kind of thinking we're
talking about megalomania here with with
someone who loves to see his own face on
national television and and this is a
sycophantic individual that should never
be taken seriously in my opinion i think
it's uh let me see if i can try and find
this
oh yeah where he's in his study with his
picture of himself and the candle he has
a candle of himself
yes in his backpack i might do something
like that sounds exciting
i gotta be honest yeah exactly exactly
do you want ian running national health
policy
where's where we gotta get the the a
nice sketch of tim behind there we go
yeah
there we go a candle of tim looking so
here's the photo snap it's from the
doctor
in his work at workplaces office with a
portrait of himself but i would do it as
a joke
to be fair we do have a big tim cast on
the wall but someone sent us that
but it's not just that he has pillows he
has candles of himself he literally has
to go on the mainstream media that loves
and adores him he never goes on the
media that questions he never goes on
the media that dares to ask him a
legitimate hard question he never dares
to go after opposition voices and if he
was really
caring about people's health he would
address the hard questions we literally
at one point on on my show on newsmax
had him had a had a fouchy watch and we
asked him for something like
70-something days and we finally gave up
because it got silly but at the end of
the day he hasn't gone on anything
alternative if the if the theory which
the data does not actually support is
that
conservatives and trump supporters etc
are the ones that are the big hesitant
folks about this then why wouldn't you
go to where they are and have a
conversation and say okay i'll take some
questions but that's a the data doesn't
suggest that number one number two is
because he doesn't want pushback anytime
someone questions anything he gets so
red watch rand paul question him the
next time i think i think sanjay gupta
is a good example of why he won't right
because joe rogan didn't let that slide
biden wouldn't either he like hid in his
basement during the uh election cycle
last time he just didn't want to get the
truth the truth is not the friends of
these people right so so to bring it
back to chicago we also have i think the
nypd the uh fire department in new york
cpd we've got nurses doctors
i'm not going to say that it's the
majority i think in chicago it's a
substantial amount i think they said
something like 59 of cops are vaccinated
so you've got
41 percent that aren't which means
that's seriously bad for a city like
chicago which has very serious gun
problems but there's a large portion
there was i think in new york it was
between 11 and 6 of the police were like
outright refusing that may seem like a
small percentage but in a city that big
that could mean crippling an entire
neighborhood or borough or or the the
highways who knows
so you you have these people outright
defying
the these uh these mandates
i kind of feel like
i don't want to be pessimistic but i
don't know if it will be enough i feel
like a lot of these cops are going to
are using this to negotiate their
contracts
ultimately it's not going to be enough
to actually put a dent in this and then
not to be pessimistic but what in two
three years we have social credit system
but the problem is you can't replace the
cops right so if six percent of the cops
call it just five five for argument say
we're walking off the job because of
this maxine mandate that's a to your
point in a place like new york or
chicago a big city that's a that's
several neighborhoods that suddenly
don't have police covering them there's
not a crop behind them especially in the
whole diff on the police movement of
officers that are waiting to take these
jobs we have demonized police officers
to such a degree that they're having
tough time recruiting these individuals
so you lose that percentage and to your
point about chicago crime goes back up i
mean i mean just a few months ago i mean
who wanted to be a cop no one especially
with the demonization especially with
everything that happened with black
lives matter and i think a lot of these
mandates don't have to do anything about
health i think a lot of them are loyalty
tests and that's why a lot of officers
who are not going along with the
programming not going along with the
conditioning not going along with the
agenda they're being purged and we're
seeing a lot of videos i i played a
couple videos today on my channel
specifically of police officers
resigning calling in as they're still in
uniform in their police car there's a
bunch of those videos going around as
well one of them saying some very choice
words for the uh
for the governor
of uh washington uh that are pretty uh
it must be a cold day in hell when you
convince luke rutkowski to actually
stand up for the cops no i'm not who
said i'm standing up for the cops i'm
just calling a spade a spade here and
talking about the facts here that no one
wants to be a police officer
like even saying that is still like
telling the truth about what's going on
with these officers yeah i'm not here to
pick sides i'm here to call out the bull
crap there's a lot of bull crap but we
got to be honest with the situation that
we're dealing with you don't have to be
political to say something like
these cops are being demonized and
they're they're they're coming after
them in unjust ways that doesn't mean
i'm like a fan of every single cop or
every department it's just the reality
is
like i just said i'm not i'm not
convinced the cops are going to stick
this one out i think they'll negotiate
their contracts and get some special
privileges and then probably like okay
fine whatever but i do think a lot of
the cops will quit because i think this
is a this is a hard line a lot of people
just can't cross physically i thought
about this like if someone came to you
and said you have to undergo this and
you're just like dude i i can't i can't
cross that line i will not be
be forced to do these things i'm
surprised actually that that
with with all that it takes right now i
mean i i'm not
in any way advocating this but i'm just
saying that it's funny that like people
walk in all the time and say you know
are you are you vaccinated or not the
people who aren't actually are taking a
stand because if you wanted to just fake
it you can right i mean let's fake it
very easily in a world like that we live
in today it's not hard to fake something
documentation wise or otherwise but yet
the people who are doing this truly i
think
believe it and are and they're saying
i'm willing to go down
i think it's a private medical decision
and if people want to talk to their
doctors about what makes for them but
you know can i just get off on a tangent
but what other
medical thing
could you possibly imagine somebody
walking into a
group of friends or a work environment
saying hey did you get the uh such and
such or are you taking this pill or did
you have this procedure there is no
other thing that could possibly happen
where this would be acceptable
there's actually a great meme where
someone said that they immediately went
to their boss and said if you are taking
responsibility for covid i demand to
know the status of every employee's
medical history including when they've
had the flu if they're pregnant if they
have hiv because certainly we should
take those into consideration in the
workplace if you're concerned about this
yeah the idea basically being as soon as
the employer says
we recognize our liability in this covid
then you could say okay well they right
then every other shot on the book and
these are not popular policies people
don't want to ask permission and be
granted special paperwork by the same
entity that runs the dmv to go to their
supermarket or their local restaurant
this is a whole level of absurdity and
insanity that people are protesting in
droves including people in dallas there
was an airport employee protest there
today in texas there was massive
protests in italy where police officers
used tear gas water canyons on dock
workers on union workers on protesters
standing against the insane policies
being implemented in italy where they
are pushing the agenda further faster
and quicker than almost anywhere else in
the world right now and these clashes
are not just creating protests and
fights between police officers which are
still obeying the laws
sorry obeying the decrees by by every
exact extent that they are but but this
is also having a huge effect on our
economy on our supply chains on global
trade and and these effects are are
absolutely monstrous and they're going
to be very huge one one thing that i
just we had a poll the other day from
the trafalgar group that we played on
the show that was really interesting if
you listen
to the mainstream media i think you get
the takeaway that luke had which is that
there's this widespread belief that
everyone had but a plurality of
democrats 47 43 so not just barely
almost a majority actually don't support
people losing their jobs if they don't
get the vaccine but if you listen to the
news you would think that this is widely
spread especially among the left and
it's not that's why i call him a cult
because matthew iglesias is a great
tweet he said twitter is people who are
95 further left in the average voter
arguing with people who are 75 percent
further left the average voter that
they're too far right
you you have my favorite metric because
i feel like it's the easiest to
understand for anyone who's paying
attention is that democrats 54
according to civics believe the economy
is good yeah that's insane moderate 70
of moderates say fairly bad or very bad
88 of republicans say fairly bad or very
bad and the reality is it's very bad
correct objectively thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you